a day since sarah everard's killer was
sentenced to life behind bars since one
of the most difficult days in the
metropolitan police's history as anger
rises a message from the prime minister
are there things we need to do yes there
are on across a huge range of issues
from the way
we handle these complaints to the way we
speed up the whole criminal justice
process but should we have confidence in
the police should we believe in policing
absolutely there is so much we still
don't know was wayne cousins properly
vetted should he have been suspended
sooner for indecent exposure he was
believed to be part of a whatsapp group
with fellow officers that shared
misogynistic messages five others are
now being investigated for gross
misconduct what we know with wayne
cousins is that he was labeled the
rapist within the met police
many of the female police staff that he
worked with at the met police didn't
like working with him he made them feel
uncomfortable now this is speculation
it's what i've read it's what i've been
told but if that does prove to be true
when the iopc report comes out surely
there are lessons to be learned there we
need to make sure that their colleagues
are able to speak out so the action can
be taken quickly without any kind of
fear of retribution an extra 650 new
officers will patrol busy public areas
in london and today the met police
issued guidance for anyone feeling
unsafe with a loan officer they said
they should shout for help wave down a
bus knock on a door or call 999.
what do you think about the advice to
call 999 if you feel unsafe with a loan
police officer i think that we've got to
a terrible position
if the minister for policing is telling
us that the answer to this particular
crisis
is for us to call the police on the
police in north yorkshire philip allet
the police commissioner had to apologize
for saying that women need to be
streetwise and that sarah everard should
never have submitted to the arrest
but all eyes today are on cressida dick
the government have defended the met
commissioner but polling suggests 38
think she should go to restore trust
between the public and the police
ali fortescue sky news